BlackRock which is uh the the what's
amazing to me now is the uh
the the and we've been following this I
spoke to Mullen about it when I was in
New York and he made some great points
about corporate landlords just owning
everything in America individual
landlords uh disappearing people not
having to pay their rent so then a lot
of these landlords have to sell their
properties
and then
um you know who comes in and buys some
BlackRock BlackRock or black stone same
thing right
um Blackstone buys 12
000
uh Sun Belt apartments for 5.8 billion
dollars
um
this is from Zero Hedge Wall Street
won't rest until it becomes the biggest
and perhaps only landlord in the U.S on
Wednesday Blackstone cemented its
position as America's largest
residential and commercial landlord by
buying a apartment owner preferred
apartment communities in a deal valued
at 5.8 billion demonstrating the
Unstoppable investor demand for
multi-family
I.E rental properties in Sun Belt States
according to Wall Street Journal
Blackstone will pay 25 a share in cash
for the atlanta-based Real Estate
Investment Trust
that that represents a premium of
roughly 39 over the closing price on
February the 9th day uh before Bloomberg
News reported the Reit was exploring
options including a sale
so the deal includes more than 40 uh
rental apartment properties including 12
000 units in States including Florida
Tennessee and Georgia that's what they
mean by Sun Belt preferred apartment
also owns 54 grocery anchored shopping
centers anchored by grocery stores
probably like Publix
about 70 of the deal's value is in its
rental apartments wow
so black stone
now they're ramping up its bet on U.S
rental housing Blackstone I want you to
think about this is fun we like we like
we like to read the article and go
falling down here I keep
I keep adjusting this and it doesn't
matter it just keeps
um
so listen to this Blackstone has been
aggressively ramping up its bet on U.S
rental housing The Firm has agreed to
buy two other companies that own
apartments in the past two months
building up his presence in States
including Colorado Texas Arizona and
Georgia well what do they mean by that
ramping up
it's bet on U.S rental housing well
they're betting and they're correct and
people are not gonna be able to own
homes or that more people
in the future are going to rent this is
their bet
and they're probably correct because the
cost of home ownership in this country
is
I mean ludicrous
especially in places where you'd want to
live
so companies like Blackstone go listen
the future is going to be the gig
economy
where you have people that hop from gig
to Gig
and they're going to be permanent
renters
and that's what it's gonna be
they're not going to own property they
may not even own a car
they're going to use services like uber
and Lyft and
they're going to rent an apartment
they're not going to own much of
anything and according to that article
you're going to love it you're going to
be happy and you know the American dream
is is is uh turning from home ownership
and family to something else entirely
it's really what it's becoming it used
to be the American dream as as stated
now you know the
how possible it was and
you know whether it was legit then
certainly more legit seeming than now
yes of course it didn't include everyone
but what about non-binary poets I know
yes I know that that's I under yes thank
you they were left out
but the American dream it was a family
and property kind of right Community
Based on those things family property
you own property you have a family
you're in a community there's industry
the community thrives everybody kind of
succeeds together fails together there's
a an investment there are social
commitments things are more local now
things are Global you don't have a
family everybody lives in a city
everybody's alone everybody's unonly
fans flicking their Bean everybody's
taking multiple pills just to get out of
bed in the morning and then another
round of pills just to get back into bed
at night
people are severed from their Community
they're severed
from any social commitments the only
communities they're a part of our
digital communities that are incredibly
toxic that are centered around
overthrowing the government or owning a
picture of an ape but
life has changed the American dream has
changed
and Blackstone gets this they know where
we're going they're not dummies they can
see it they go how the hell they can
afford this
they're gonna rent and they'll be happy
to do it
people go why do I need a home I don't
have a family
you gotta what do I need a home you know
I have houses and I don't really need
houses but they're good Investments and
I like houses and I certainly have
friends over but I don't I don't need a
house because I don't have a family so I
don't need a house but I guess nobody
needs anything but the reason to have it
like Ben and his wife always remind me
that I don't need a home they always go
you don't need to live in a house you
don't have a family because they're
heterosexuals so they're gonna have a
family so it means they deserve a house
so I should give my house to them
I have multiple homes I should give them
all to them but that's the point because
I don't need it as a gay guy who's
single I don't need square footage I
don't need space I'm to give it to them
uh well no they can get it they can get
their own but I'm always constantly told
I don't need a house and they're they're
they're they're they're they're right to
that to an extent because I don't have a
family
but that is why most people buy houses
so as families
um you know family formation is low and
it's happening later in life people just
don't need to buy [ __ ] houses now
you've brought up an interesting chart
here the National Rent index up 18 year
over year why don't you tell the people
about this chart that you
've brought up so it's why are you
laughing
I didn't I didn't ever say you didn't
either you and your wife have constantly
I've never said that you've constantly
if a house is like seven bedrooms before
I'm like I don't think you need seven
beds I think I've said that but I don't
think I've said it but it's it's because
yes it is you've made me feel bad for
being gay and you've said that gay
people don't deserve homes well gay
people a lot of us have more money than
you as a straight person because if you
didn't meet me you'd be working to
tilling the land I don't know what the
hell you'd be doing but gay people of
higher than average incomes and they're
creative but you're telling what if I
want to adopt kids what if I want to
adopt uh uh children I'm for that to
fill the rooms buy the space and and
fill fill the rooms if I adopted a child
could you get it for me and figure it
out yeah it's a long process though you
need how involved do I have to be I read
a book
you read a book about gay adoption no
not gay adoption but just adoption in
general it was it and Bubba Watson's
book He's a PGA Tour player he talks
about adopting kids and it took him a
long time yeah Barbara Watson he's got
tons of money he's a millionaire he had
to get on planes isn't he a drunk though
no no he's sober he's dead sober oh
who's the drunk who loves Trump uh John
Daly yeah because him I get they go
let's give it a take a beat before we
give you a kid but so it's I've always
heard this that adoption is very hard
that's my whole thing with abortion a
boy and I'm for abort but I'm like
listen Maybe we make adoption easier so
that it's not we're not putting these
kids in uh Mills right we we it's a nice
timeout for the woman nine months nice
time out you get to eat whatever you
want sit on the bed put her on the
Tempur-Pedic get her a tub of ice cream
and then give the kid to somebody who
can't have it I always thought that was
the way to do it give her some pickles
you know they get weird Cravings give
her pickles a tub of rocky road pop the
baby out and then give it to a family
but it why is it so hard to adopt a kid
I I think everything is about I hate to
say it I don't want to sound like a
paranoid person but it's really all
about it's all sex traffic yeah no it's
it's
it's true it's like CPS the child
protective services is like and I want
to have a Eliza blue on the uh human
trafficking did you follow her that's
great I want to know if she knows
anything about the CPS because they were
they're crazy what they do they just
take kids and then you know they go you
know they we nobody knows what happens
to the kids but they they take them out
of these situations that are supposedly
bad and I'm not saying that all of these
situations aren't bad but these kids end
up in foster care and in in the link
between that and trafficking it's crazy
but I think we need to make adoption
easier but what I'm saying about uh this
is when you guilt me and you attack me
and say you don't because you've said
multiple times to me when I had my
mansion in Palm Springs or my my uh big
big uh kind of like a mini mansion in
the valley and you were like oh you
don't need this but I told you a million
[ __ ] times I wanted to have a
Christmas party with Logan Paul and
Barry Weiss that's the whole [ __ ]
point of having the square footage is to
is to have a party with everyone one and
and you dim and you demean I'm just
saying I don't want to be demeaned
tell them about the rental chart so it
says here that uh like if you look at
the chart here 2020 to 2021 it was down
1.4 but then 21 to 2022 up 17.8 United
States annual rent growth yeah more
people are going to be renting from here
on out that seems to be the case yeah
it's gonna be you know we shut it down
uh we destroyed people's ability to earn
a living and earn income we [ __ ] up
People's Credit you know it we we we we
we stopped you know a lot of forward
momentum that people had in their lives